I'm sorry typhus game so excited for
this game so excited for this game so
excited for this game so excited to this
game so I actually only notice that this
game was out like a couple of days ago
house like why does this look familiar
guys I read something it was like PT and
what Alison Rhodes loved child and I was
like ah because it reminds me of hours
of road um and I was so ready for that
game but they're not the same didn't
happen so yeah I have high hopes of this
it had very positive reviews on Steam so
I'm hoping it's gonna spook me visage is
hard patience thorough investigation
wait I didn't read out oh look
that reminds me of Sam Hill 4 and PT a
little bit of both you start Hill for
the room when you're trapped inside
[Music]
SADS glass studio
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
someone kidnapped a husband and wife
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
they are taking their time with this gun
[Music]
oh my god those kids here
but this is getting very straight to the
point I thought this game was gonna be
slow like not in a bad way but oh my god
I don't know if I've seen a kid be shot
in a game before okay with it yeah I
don't know what oh hey PG missed you
missed you loads during but you
sometimes don't flatter yourself oh
never fun okay that sounds exactly like
the sound of the door opening in people
hello Mary in PT hello how are you
why is this just like real life I've
just been making my game leave me alone
hmm craft beer mmm okay how do I drop
you again II know
right click know what I forgot how to
drop you oh I don't drop this can okay
whatever this kind of staying with us Oh
put it in the clock great this is a
great start to the game I'm just gonna
carry on your character sanity will
affect your gameplay standing too long
the dark will decrease your character's
sanity a monk's varying other elements
your character 17 is represented by the
brain icon in the lower left corner of
the screen if you see the brain clearly
your parent society is dangerously low
and dangerous events will occur the red
cloud icon appears from your own
stressful situation okay hold to toggle
rotation after drop ah thank God it's
you she's the same the same button to
pick up and drop okay I gotta get out
the darkness cuz I'm gonna start going
crazy okay let's let's carry on playing
the game oh repair with would like old
repair with light bulb repair okay these
are paranormal events and they decrease
my sanity balls so don't even have a
light bulb
okay I'm so
and take your whole family to defeat
take a day off and show your loved ones
how much you care about them on this
wonderful vacation
on another note today we got a special
guest with us
so something creepy is gonna happen with
that radio because we know how privet
all privet all pivot all the radio
wasn't PT so yeah it would not be
surprised
whoo difference I wouldn't it be cool if
there was like something in the
reflection that you could only see in
little bits that is actually really
really cool me I'm just looking at stuff
just leave me alone let me do my thing
[Music]
well [ __ ] why why why why why I told you
ice cream why I was just opening it
freaking thing why why is that scary
I actually pulled a neck muscle because
I moved to take with me okay
oh I just remembered how creepy
bathrooms are and I don't know why I
just closed the door myself I think it's
cause it's nice and warm warm yes I can
feel the temperature of the game I mean
it's a nice and nice and light I like
that I like light things can't see my
reflection I don't like that door no I
I'm actually really scared so I don't
know how long I can play this game for
okay I'm gonna just have to be strong
I should probably still carry on looking
down yay panda screw downstairs
yeah nice panda I like you okay
I did a chapter and insidious friend but
but why wait what what yeah close F I
keep thinking II okay I'm scared
I know I know this hallway I don't know
I know a hallway I know something
happens in a hallway but he kill this
little picture okay I'm just gonna get
out sighs Oh
music why am I freaking out I haven't
played a horror game in so long I feel
like pretty rusty
oh wait I am okay good this is why I
play games with you nah I'm not gonna
let down the creepy hall again I refuse
scheisse that door wasn't open earlier
[Music]
now now
oh my god oh my god no no I know this I
know this I know this from Allison Road
why am i going inside I know this from
the trailer I don't have a shadow I'm a
freaking vampire a shadow a reflection I
can't even do English okay come on
what's wrong with me right I can do this
easy pills acts as an aid for your
character sanity they are essential to
your survival when your star C is low
they are only viable option okay okay
okay
I don't feel too bad about this okay
glorious I don't want to go in here nope
nope I don't want to go in there I've
watched that Alessandro trailer and I
refuse
it's oh my god kids rooms the freakin
worst right life switch
were you up okay oh my gosh why is that
why are you I think this is actually um
- that closet right in the other room
oh my gosh opening doors is hard okay
yeah so that's the closet
can I see it can to see what are they
funny very awkward opening these I don't
know if it's just me being weird I'm
like I'm just moving my mouse very large
oh yeah
oh we go okay oh yes
another dimly lit room perfect this is
miss study oh my gosh it's not just
dimly lit it's like pitch black no no no
running running Ronnie this is real
freaky I can do this
I got this someone likes their beers the
craft bears a lot whiter the aim of this
game cuz I actually just forgot for a
while that we saw a whole family get
married so am I like wait I might be
married of it what was I the same person
from the beginning nope nope hmm I just
have a frickin ponder in my inventory
for some reason okay so I didn't need
any of this I didn't eat any of this I
don't need
you this nope apparently not great Wow I
don't understand what I'm doing okay I'm
thinking a little less nervous now
though nope me
cool posters why this so they're so used
who puts up posters like it's like they
just found the post and scrunch them up
in that pocket and then put them up in
their room I was always super careful of
my posters so that they look nice in my
wall but maybe this isn't me I don't
know okay
this room is too dark No babadook do I
even have is there oh yeah of course I
was like is there even a clock in here
okay this doesn't have a light in it
that's nice mmm
just go into the bathroom sweet we made
it I think we explored everywhere why
have we found like nothing
where have I not been is that you light
bulb hello yeah it's not even light bulb
okay perfect new achievement unlocked I
became a handyman
um Oh balls are just realized this
frickin place okay
so say that oh dear can't go down to the
basement what a shame oh well okay okay
when when when when did that happen
I would go in here and fix it but I I
literally can't even see screw screw
this
they all need it okay how am I supposed
to fix you when I can't frickin see Oh
No he's got to be on the ceiling
somewhere nope
oh well I don't know this is still this
way for later okay
are we doing there's gotta be something
oh hello I feel like I'm getting a lot
of like items to use but I'm not having
to use any yet
oh hello okay I got something
it's glue ok let's close that one cool
happy we did that let's face our fears
shall we
I should really don't want to you know
though I didn't do that I didn't do that
where's my pills how do I use it use the
pill use the pill mmm sanity back to
normal Yong Yong Yong Yong oh I did it
okay
nothing happened oh hello this is the
light for here oh no that's so creepy no
[ __ ] jammed
ah okay I have I have a lightbulb use I
don't like that that was so subtle I'm
not gonna do again I'm gonna do again
there's no good again opals da bulls I
can't use either of these doors I'm
playing its freakin game and it knows it
okay cool we're out well that bird was
not there before what are you doing here
bear no I'm gonna fix you bowls I didn't
even have a lighter what what did I miss
them
boudreaux's oh no no don't read the
doors I would let's take the Kendall yep
cuz we still don't even have a night is
this like literally no point should we
take some pills
nah we'll be fine
I see
cans hovering hmm okay I can don I don't
really need you I'm also safe oh I don't
know whether to be happy or or not okay
what's on the TV what we're watching a
black-and-white film
someone's wedding
that was very unnerving why is he
holding a headlight okay what are we
watching is this okay for the kids right
okay anyway um no bowls why companies
nope is that my house is that this house
I love this content not available and
early access oh okay that's fine should
we press it again I don't know all right
first of all we'll use we'll use the
light source to have a little look at
these pictures these little Polaroids
Sarah is kuipers cute cutie I got the
key to the basement I don't wanna go to
the basement basements always creepy
wait do I have any tea left no we ran
out date now that we're done with that
let's do this again
nope okay nothing happens stuck so let's
look for a room have renauldi
[ __ ] hell bulls I don't even know
what that was have we voice this is this
lights like flowers like flowers dad's
not gonna eat me okay um anyway I was
trying to say is that the study room
that's upstairs
okay then is there anything in that
hallway oh my gosh guys I just noticed
there's a freaking girl in the hallway
oh good that's what this water on the
window that can you see the girl can you
see her she's here can you see can you
see dude I thought I had the key to the
basement [ __ ] Bulls I'm just eating all
my pills yeah it worked okay
wait this is the basement I thought this
would be the kitchen
oh I don't why are there so many
pictures that's quite disturbing yay I
have a later line as they used as a -
source of light to explore the house and
they last a limited amount of time they
will not present present prevent stress
build-up standing in the dark for the
lights and will decrease your side
character sanity please stop freaking me
out I'm just looking at my lighter I
don't really want to go down that so I'm
gonna go in here which already makes my
70 bad some reason I guess cuz it's so
dark in here
hi do you have light anywhere please is
there light oh nope yes much better
I cannot live like this not with food
like that that is one what my wanted
kind of like hey hey it's food being
everywhere cuz it stinks yeah we need to
do washing out looks nice
let's get on this it's just cause it's
just filled with beer of course no I'm
good
I was thinking that might be like a dead
bird in there but I guess this wasn't
inspire of Resident Evil 7 is inspired
by Petey so we'll just look out for that
fetus baby oh oh it's so cute another
design that's the best oh ok I can open
a lot of doors of this can I like this
ski ski skis
doing a lot for me is other 2 entrances
to the basement this makes me uneasy and
Mary's here though so I guess that's
that's a good thing I didn't really want
to go down there but then I also don't
want to go here it's October yeah that
is true ok this is a nice bright room ok
hmm oh this is gonna be that door that
like leads around to the other side of
the house right and this is why I was ja
[Music]
yeah yeah I knew it
okay cool so at least we knew that now
we can get back there quickly if we
never feel the need your frickin
microwave Jesus I don't want to eat
whatever you're offering me I don't food
look at this place is ridiculous I live
off beer I don't need food I'm a liquid
person I think I have a light bulb yes I
do
take no that's examined
take news I'm a builder man um okay oh
my god used to here should have used to
here should have used it here I can't do
this I can't do this oh [ __ ] I can't do
this
I'm got my cup I'm scared can I pick can
I pick this up okay okay I know my
lighter please okay cool
I can't do this I can't do this Effendi
that's looking I can do this I can do
this I can do this I can do this oh I
can do this no this is shot it okay let
me find a light I can do this I can do
this I can do this I can do this I can
do this oh no oh no this is this is the
room what is this part of the freaking
house this is this is not okay this is
not a normal part of the house this is
the whole ninu die bulls to the Bulls I
don't know what's happening I'm just
trying to like my way in the darkness
dolls nope nope nope nope shall we shall
we shall we shall we shall we um yeah
true true that true that where's my
pills where's my pills outwards with
pills up here excuse me why is there
flashing lights
I don't really oh okay I don't Britney
understand I'm just gonna start munching
my pills and just um pick up this camera
my hands are full I'm carrying my
lighter and the pills I don't know what
to do right so I'm I've forgotten how to
put them back what
oh god what have I gotten myself into
Oh God Oh God
okay
I don't like this like the babadook I
swear this is the babadook
I'm common I'm going the way you're
asking me to you I'm doing I'm doing the
things you maybe walk around in a circle
why did you do that
look hmm
is she there it's not the girl crawl in
here let's just let's just fall in here
it's gooey please don't know why I love
this i watch Dawn's daily uh I just love
this I am I'm totally burning the appeal
of the scare factor this whole moment
right here
pose for me okay that was that was the
syringe nope
you already come in there I'm gonna give
it that way
okay I feel like I'm getting very slowly
as I'm paying this I don't know if I'm
just kidding myself here I mean like
should we explore here or should we just
go this one yes perfect grand okay so um
having like a sheet like that and then
having shadows through it always very
much reminds me of Sam Hill they used to
do a little creepy tactics like that all
the time and they work trilliant so good
they were so good they used to do it
especially with the whole fixed angle
thing so like the angle would suddenly
change you suddenly just see dance and
you are you only even sure if it's a
mannequin or if it's a freaking nurse
what is down here oh okay good I don't
have to go that um what is this am i
coming like the other way I feel like I
am I feel like I'm messing up the way
that I should be going I think I am okay
okay sorry sorry the old girl I'll go
the way that was supposed to go dude
where did you it just stops huh ah no it
doesn't stop okay so it's strange that
there was like a whole nother room down
there I don't know is that strange to
you was it was it just strange to me I I
just thought that was a bit weird so how
about oh I'm just holding too much stuff
on there just walking around this house
absolutely terrified just like did you
do the camera and I like it this is
never ending which I'm glad I'm just a
map desire on the whole entire time I'm
sorry if it's spoiling the mood I don't
care oh actually I do care because isn't
is supposed to affect my sanity okay
is that like are you supposed to be all
good eye-opener is it just because I
find your controls awkward it's too dark
for me I don't have candle like duh so -
a - a - a - a tire I literally don't
have anything I don't know what to do
what is my life hi
[ __ ] how balls to the walls like I
literally okay wait use my brain use my
brain can I not turn this on is it is it
though
maybe it is because I can't see anything
so in theory if I can't see it can't be
scared of it no case it's got a little
girl by it your light is nearly empty
what I thought it was like
indestructible my turn it lied to me oh
okay I can turn on this well let's turn
that off then oh look the lighter is sad
it's sad square for the company all
that's so cute I love that sometimes
when I click to use the camera okay
screw this room we're out we're out
we're out we're out
why is everything red okay I'm pretty
insane right now so I'm just gonna take
some pills don't mind me just gonna take
my pills you know and hope that
everything everything's gonna be okay
[Music]
what's happening
huh
guilt this way
I'm not ready things I need my camera
anymore but I feel kind of safe with
something out I don't know why I like
this little cuddly bear it's so cute
I like that one especially okay but this
is to my guilt so I'm guessing I am
still the man from the beginning of the
game right what say man they like men's
hands who knows Ben was a woman who
kills the family and this is me going to
their house wow that's a massive cuddly
panda yes so this is me going through
their house that I killed but would it
be because it looks lived in but yeah it
also looks kind of like like it's been
abandoned from I all I mean place is a
mess
food is gone a little bit rotten but not
too rotten oh it's a two house year ago
this is cute
I'm Lucy hello Lucy I want to be your
friend Lucy oh it's a girl from the ring
no no it's holding her Picou friend did
it what did it do kill the bird what did
it do I'm Lucy Lucy Lucifer I want to be
your friend Lucy told you knew it so
that that came out of the radio didn't
it oh okay so I've got key well she's
been tested on this this little girl
also Lucy's together we saw earlier what
to bots what's this and get rid of it
get rid of it Lucy get rid of it get rid
of it get rid of watch
do it Lucy get rid of it Lucy
get rid of it disease get rid of it Lucy
am I supposed to do something
[Music]
[Music]
yeah guessing she killed her badge
get rid of her Lucy getting rid of it
Lucy
mmm
Oh my kid well I guess that makes sense
because that's where we first saw her
[Music]
okay that's weird that life switch has
has literally been ripped out of the
wall put the toys back in their place no
yelling close the TV when leaving the
basement ask dad for the key if you need
something in the storage room don't try
to go in the locked rooms do not turn
off the TV monitor have fun so like my
prize is just to put her in here so she
basically shut up and just get out of
that rain
what [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
wait wait wait just let me pick up this
one I'm confused I can't remember how to
do my things oh god I don't know what I
just felt like something touched me in
the back okay okay
okay I just felt like something touched
me the back but it didn't I'm just I'm
just freaking out like I literally saw
something actually touched my real back
in like real life and all the light
switches have gone and I am going insane
and in real life I no stop I don't we
take my pills please
[Music]
I don't even have a freaking candlestick
what are you on about what just frickin
drop it then I don't understand this
system just let me cannot store a for
them
well freakin put it back and just I'll
screw this I'm getting annoyed like it
cuz I can't work my things and I'm
getting stressed out I'm scared and I
can't member the way upstairs and like I
can't store my things because I don't
understand how to use it anymore because
it's empty right so I got to drop it
with F and then God screw this my life
what is it [ __ ] a duck go to this one I
can't concentrate when I'm freaking out
there's too many keys Brett
pick you up yeah and up right how do I
put this candle down use it no don't use
the camera put okay and then get the
like turn and use that okay sweet I'm
getting you think really aggressive my
realizes this no no I just want to stay
by my candle dude oh well this would
make sense you know follow the light
switches the game is going a bit bad
apologies
I need Citra pills
[Music]
how do I open this okay
can I put candle down please please
please please please somewhere somewhere
around here cuz I just want to touch
these guys as I won't touch them there's
one touch them and see if they disappear
but they they don't [ __ ] disappear
well we're going um nope she's coming
she's coming I need to take my pills
she is coming I need to take my pills I
need to go bother like I'm confused
again yeah I need to go by the light I
need to go buy a candle where's my
candle candle candle I thought I put you
here candle candle
[Music]
okay that's it for tonight guys but join
me next week where I'll be playing more
of this game and we'll try and finish it
even though I keep complaining that I'm
confusing - oh I'm Greg it's a good
amount of like confusion feeling a bit
disoriented but then you find out you're
like oh of course you know there's
there's clues there are subtle clues
telling you where to go and that's
that's the perfect thing about it it's
it's subtle it's not obvious and the
problem with most horror games nowadays
is like either they give you direction
and it's very obvious direction and it's
just like monsters here and you're
killing the monsters and whatever or
it's no direction at all completely just
you in like some spooky I don't know so
expansion a nice spooky mental asylum
and things just pop out on you I mean
that is happening - but there's more to
it and it's more of a story and I
appreciate that and I'm really like I'm
gonna be alone forever I'm gonna be
alone forever but I'm getting used to
the thought separated nights so maybe
I'm now I'm gonna be alone forever
I'm gonna be alone forever
[Music]
I'm gonna be a loop for ever
I'm gonna be alone forever and I'm
getting used to this dog except at night
so maybe I'm not I'm gonna be alone
forever I'm gonna be a lose forever
[Music]